so this is memories of boom-boom
mountain well chase I thought you are
not Jason you yes I am oh okay well
Jason so what do you think of this
episode person who clearly has a penis I
think it was great because I love
adventure time you do know you're gonna
do Jason I don't have a penis this is
the penis only couch out this is mrs.
Jason this is Jory you have also seen
her in a lot of videos uh I guess on the
AI video and dragon board and stuff
suburban nights right you're also a huge
adventure time fan would have been and
more except last week she's like I don't
know you're fine but now you're all
dolled up and everything and we got
memories of boom boom Mountain and this
is the one where this mountain is really
upset and sad that these roughhousing
guys are roughhousing and Finn tries to
solve everybody's problems because he
made boom-boom as a baby and that began
is vowed to help anyone in deep
boom-boom I guess so but the mountain
has a problem and then like all these
are things have a problem and I thought
the lesson wasn't gonna be a game please
everybody all the time
but at the end it's like you can't
please everybody
and I don't know how to feel about that
but I know that you really liked this
episode so I'm curious what you thought
about it
well actually I really did think that
that was kind of the purpose that was
silly and it was ridiculous but I kind
of felt like Finn at one moment in time
was like a politician he was actually he
was the president at that point if you
think about it anything you do anything
you try to do he says it exactly there
there are things people don't want that
other people want I don't know what
do and I mean was it the right solution
I suppose so I mean we have a snapshot
in time but you know that steam that's
blocking the mountains vision that's
gonna go away soon I mean yeah these are
gonna happen it's all gonna fall apart
it's just I feel like okay kids
here you go kind of a happy ending and
also it's hilarious but yeah yeah I
thought they were gonna show like all
this stuff was gonna crumble and fall
apart or sound like that was gonna be
the punch I and it never does
and I guess on the one hand like from a
comedic standpoint it's like oh that's
well pretty but I didn't see that coming
like you know the laughing is with this
dolphins in love with me it's like
that's not a problem that's awesome and
they ride the dolphin up it's like I get
you can't predict it but it's like at
the same time still kind of a kid show
and I just don't know if that's a good
thing to really sort of be leaning tour
it's like no no if you can't find the
answers cuz you just haven't found the
answer there's some way to make
everybody happy and I just wasn't sure I
don't know well what do you read into
that well yeah
dude I have a mom and this is tough
because hey now I see your point
I guess she wasn't watching it as a mom
I just I thought and that's it you're
absolutely right
dammit okay I I didn't even know we were
arguing on a subject like this pointing
something I'm not even aware I'm trying
to win well fine
no I I didn't think about it that way I
really enjoyed the part I think more
than the end lesson because if you think
about it two kids kind of have a very
short attention span and yes this is a
short attention span and it's haha
hilarious but I think that build-up to
Finn of really going I don't know what
to do and you see his eyes change and
everything and he's really going insane
it's it gives kids the idea it gives
them two ideas one is clearly if you try
and save the world it's gonna be hell
and it's difficult but also I love the
fact that he did this he's a hero
because well nobody helped him someone's
gotta help
someone and I'll do it because nobody
helped me and I thought that was a
really neat lesson that I think we all
think is too funny but you forget that
that's a good lesson to teach the kids
well nobody helped me instead of saying
forget it you know he's like well no I
remember how it felt I want to help
people so they don't have to feel that
way which I thought was really
heartwarming but then that's what the
elements I really like I really like how
much Finn especially it just there is
just that need to help and I think that
is just so likeable um and and just how
much he like really gets into it you
like you know it's like if he can help
something he gets like really say let's
go let's go um and but yeah it's
interesting because you never know if
it's one of those things where because
you sometimes you come across people
where they feel like they always have to
be needed if that makes sense it's
almost I guess because I know a lot of
people that really go searching for a
kind of like Finn like you know just
people that help and it it doesn't
always end up this way likes and like
you were saying with you know just the
whole world seems to be you know
everyone has something that they need
help with and he's trying to help them
all and it becomes too much um and I've
just known so many people that have
gotten themselves in that predicament
and usually you gotta tell look it's
okay take time for yourself you can't
save the world but here you could so
it's like as a comedian I think that's
really funny but as a kid show I find
that very trouble I think so it's like I
didn't know what to make of this um you
know maybe that's just part of it it's
like well don't look at too much as the
kid show sometimes just let a kid show
beat something goofy and it's just
something goofy one I think that's part
of the charm especially for me and I
think for a lot of adults too is that
just because it's a kids show it doesn't
have to teach you everything and we have
Sesame Street for that we have people
for that you know sometimes it's just
fun to kind of see a little something
yes a little bit of a message but
sometimes you know kids can't be
learning 24/7 they're already going to
school you're they're already got their
parents on their back don't do this
don't do that clean your room do this do
that it's nice to just
watch something and it's stupid and it's
ridiculous and it's hilarious maybe I
get the seed planted in my head with
that tiny little moment you know with
fit helping but in the end you just need
to relax I mean you don't constantly
study as adults we're not kind of I mean
okay maybe some of you but I don't you
know I like to watch crap TV because
well I don't want to think cuz I'm done
every but everybody needs to kind of
zone out and just have fun and I think
that's what Adventure Time is good for
it's got little bits and pieces and it's
fun to analyze it but in the end it's
it's just it's nice it's just a nice
little boy waste of time goofy a waste
of adventure time never never waste
adventure time oh I can see that I mean
I could see it's just like you know hey
let's just go have fun something goofy
you think it's gonna leave this
direction it doesn't I may because like
I said I think just because especially I
think I can't come from background of
people that really do this I think I
kinda used to be that person that just
felt like you need to save everybody or
you know why especially that somebody
put best when he says some people just
really need to be needed and and I think
that can be trouble for some people and
I guess when you implant that a young
age like you know know you can always
solve every problem you know you just
have to look hard to know that it's like
but it's like you're going to lose and
there's gonna be times to lose but then
again there's probably other episodes
that teach that like even the past ones
I feel like they've kind of done that
like in the jiggler episode where it's
like they think they're gonna take care
of the pet but it it's out of their
control and it wasn't their place so
it's you might be rhyming it's just a
balance but also if you think about it -
you have to stop you do have to find a
point in time where you stop right it
looks like everything's done and they're
like it we're done here and they move on
and they ride the dolphin cuz hello who
wouldn't it's a good lesson ride your
girlfriend right
always if it is a girl for coven mail to
do better by release and another reason
is you you just so glad you got the look
of dog dolphin by relation you know if a
dog in a dolphin can learn to get along
why candy yeah I mean really but you
have they should put that a movie
somewhere you back where you are and you
go okay I've done everything I can
this kind of looks to be about the best
I can do I'm done
hmm so it works right it's there's a
lesson you have to know when does that
you know your lesson yeah you know I
maybe I'm just trying to argue it for
myself but I did realize that cuz you
said you know everything eventually is
going to stop you know like you know
someone's gonna stop doing something the
whole cycles gonna fall apart but at the
very least he did his best and maybe
that's the joke that the very least he
did his best you know and not realizing
it might fall apart whatever any and he
took off but at the very least he tried
and maybe that's like the setup for it
so very well be that may be smarter I'm
giving you credit for who knows so
you're not coming back probably not -
goodbye less apparence Joey you won't be
missed